joining me now is Congressman James
Comer chairman of the house oversight
committee Congressman good to see you
tonight d.c's district attorney has said
that it isn't his fault that criminals
back on the street it's an issue with
their uh forensic processing that the
processor of forensic evidence I guess
is not up to Snuff in DC I thought I was
dreaming or having a nightmare when I
heard that that takes the cake yeah talk
about passing the buck I mean this is
one example of many prosecutors in all
these blue cities that just aren't doing
their job they they are soft on crime
they're passionate about Criminal
Justice Reform they want to give
criminals more rights than than
law-abiding citizens and as a result
there's a direct correlation with soft
on crime prosecutors and increased crime
in Washington DC is the perfect example
of that we have a terrible group of
prosecutors in this city and that's why
we have skyrocketing crime well they're
saying well just help us become a state
and all will be well I say well how
about Maryland that's run by democrats
how's Baltimore doing Illinois is run by
billionaire J.B pritzker how's Chicago
doing right so but they think statehood
is gonna they can't even run this city
let alone have it be a state no there's
no way they could be self-sustainable as
a state they want to be a state for one
reason to be able to have two more
Democrat U.S senators that's that's the
whole thing it's all about politics it
has nothing to do with Public Safety it
has nothing to do with sustainability
it's all about politics and trying to
tip the scale of power in the House of
Representatives and in the U.S Senate
and I believe that the leaders in
Washington DC have really done a great
Injustice to the people they think that
all the problems in Washington DC are as
a result of not having representation in
Washington D.C when they have
Representatives they just want two more
they just want two reliable Democrat
Senator voters that's it right that's it
the city votes 85 percent Democrat uh 85
percent of the time the residents vote
Democrat but I'll tell you what we saw
in New York state during the midterm
elections or the Democrat voters turned
their back on the Democrat Party because
of one issue and that was crime still
elected hokel though and they still I
mean how much do they have to suffer all
right we mentioned this in the angle but
for the attorney general not to jump on
what is obvious to me growing
anti-christian bias in the United States
and criminal activity geared toward
Christians we'll learn more about what
this Killer really felt and who knows
but we've had these targetings of the
pro-life centers of of pregnancy centers
across the country churches have been
attacked and the the rhetoric toward
Christians they're Terror if you're a
Christian in a Bible believe in
Christian you're a terrorist essentially
yeah Merrick Garland's Legacy is not
going to be what he had hoped when he
became attorney general people close to
Merrick Garland told me he's really
concerned about his legacy I mean not to
mention the the attacks on Trump the tax
and Republicans the way he's turned his
back on Christians the way he's turned
his back on law-abiding citizens will
never be forgotten and it's it's created
irreparable damage to the Department of
Justice and this is another example uh
the grand jury in New York has adjourned
for a month the one investigating Donald
Trump
it's just a scam this whole thing is a
scam sham and everything wrapped up in
between yeah it was a political stunt
from day one you can't have a local
attorney Prosecuting a presidential
candidate for federal campaign Finance
violations that occurred five years ago
I mean the whole thing was a joke the
doj passed on this case that's why
Congressman Jordan and I asked for the
D.A Mr Bragg to come to Washington and
explain to us we got to put pressure on
this this is no Authority he's got to be
dropped he was two levels of government
below what was appropriate to prosecute
a case they're trying to strag this out
are they not just harassment at this
point Congressman great to see you thank
you the city deserves better D.C
deserves better hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else